Vaccines help our immune system defend against
bacterial and viral infections but soon they
may help fight off a completely different
type of illness: Heroin addiction.
Drug addiction is usually characterized by
craving, tolerance (the need for more drugs
over time) and withdrawal.
These three factors work together to drive
the need for more heroin.
Addictions are hard to break.
Don’t believe me?
Try giving up coffee in the mornings or even
just cutting back to one cup a day and let
me know how that works for you.
I betcha get a headache.
Well heroin withdrawal feels much, much worse
than coming off of caffeine and symptoms include
nausea, diarrhea, pain, anxiety, and muscle
spasms that some believe inspired the phrase
“kicking the habit” .
Staying away from heroin while wracked with
withdrawal symptoms is one of the most brutal
challenges in fighting addiction and the potential
for relapse is high.
Recently, scientists at The Scripps Research
Institute announced development of a clinically
viable vaccine to heroin.
Basically, the vaccine taps into the body’s
own defense system, training the immune system
to recognize heroin and produce anti-heroin
antibodies.
After vaccination, exposure to the drug would
cause a surge in anti-heroin antibodies that
would bind and eliminate the drug before it
could activate the receptors responsible for
its euphoric high.
Hopefully, this would discourage vaccinated
users from taking heroin because they wouldn’t
feel the “high”.
This vaccine has only been tested in rodents
and non-human primates, but if it were approved
for use in human patients, it could prevent
heroin addiction in first time users and stave
off relapse in patients who have already suffered
through heroin withdrawal.
Additionally, the vaccine could be used in
combination with buprenorphine and methadone,
two weak opioid compounds used to manage craving
and withdrawal symptoms, to improve the outcomes
of patients experiencing heroin withdrawal.
Heroin abuse is a growing problem in the United
States.
Almost 13,000 deaths were attributed to heroin
overdose in 2015 and the number is growing
every year.
Heroin is considered part of the opioid epidemic
because when some of the 12.5 million people
abusing prescription drugs lose access to
legal opiates, they turn to more potent street
drugs like heroin to maintain their high.
If approved, therapies like this new vaccine
may act as internal reinforcement for patients
who are seeking help for drug addiction.
And the fact that there is a medical treatment
for their condition may help patients and
those around them identify addiction as a
medical disease as opposed to a failing of
self-control, which could shift all of our
thinking to remove stigma, alleviate shame,
and provide hope.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
We mentioned that heroin is a pretty deadly
drug, but what makes heroin so dangerous in
the first place?
Find out in this video here.
Do you have any other drug-related questions
you’d like us to answer?
Let us know down in the comments, don’t
forget to subscribe and come back here for
more Seeker.